you might have heard of the principle of
least privilege
everyone should only be granted the
minimum permissions that are needed to
perform their jobs
grant too much access and you've created
security risk
grants you little access and soon enough
you'll be inundated with support tickets
from users requesting that you grant
them access to do their jobs
it's a balancing act between security
and developer productivity
and it's one of those things that's
easier said than done
on google cloud there is a boatload of
iem roles loaded with dozens of
individual permissions for a wide array
of apis and services
google cloud active assist has a whole
category of tools under security
umbrella called policy intelligence
policy intelligence uses data and
machine learning to help you optimize
your iem policies troubleshoot access
issues better predict the impact of any
permission changes across your project
or organization and simplify access
reviews
let's do a quick walkthrough of the
services and tools that make up policy
intelligence by imagining a few
scenarios and asking a few questions
that might come up
let's say that you've got a cloud
storage bucket that has some sensitive
data in it
question
who in my organization can read the
files in this bucket
answer that with policy analyzer which
can tell you which user accounts service
accounts and groups have certain roles
and permissions on a specific resource
including access gained through service
account impersonation
okay how about this
you've got a new employee joining the
team who actually does need to use the
files in that bucket but looks like they
can't access them with their user
account
the question
why can't they access the bucket the
answer to this one is found with policy
troubleshooter
you give it an email a resource and a
permission and policy troubleshooter
will examine the im policies that apply
to the resource to reveal whether any of
the user's roles include the required
permissions
it will also tell you whether or not the
user is in a group that has those
permissions
next you're doing an audit of your
project's iam roles and permissions and
find that there's a service account
that's been used in one of your
application's back-ends
first how do you make sure that this
service account is still needed
for that there's activity analyzer
activity analyzer lets you see when your
service accounts and keys were last used
to call google api
with the dates of the most recent
authentication activity you can more
easily identify service accounts and
service account keys that may no longer
be in use and safe to deactivate or
delete
okay what have you learned that yes this
service account is still in use but it's
also overprovisioned with extra
permissions you think it doesn't need
what would happen if you swapped out one
of those roles for a more restricted one
answer
well you could just make the change and
see what breaks but that's probably not
the best course of action
instead you can use policy simulator to
simulate a policy change to make sure
nothing breaks and apply the change if
you're satisfied with the results
this removes the risk of accidentally
breaking an application or process by
removing a role that you incorrectly
thought was unnecessary
finally when it comes to the principle
of least privilege there's one more
question that you might have
how do i start and make progress when i
have lots of over-provisioned roles
well here's a great answer
i am recommender
these are recommendations that
automatically surface on your cloud
console letting you know when accounts
may be overprovisioned with too many
permissions
these recommendations are based on
actual usage data and include
alternative roles that you can grant
instead with just a couple of clicks
recommendations are updated constantly
and you have the option of dismissing
them or applying them and even after
that you can easily roll back the
changes
together these tools make up active
assist policy intelligence that makes
applying the principle of least
privilege less of a burden
in the next couple of videos in this
series i'm going to dig a little deeper
into each of these tools so you can get
familiar with what they're capable of
and understand when you would use each
of them
in the meantime if you want to learn
more about policy intelligence check out
cloud.google.com
policy intelligence